slithering in at number eight say hello
to titanoboa it all looks like fun and
games until someone gets squeezed to
death by a katana ball
this mechanical monster was built by
artist Charlie Brinson and his team in
Calgary Canada but how does clever
engineering make a robot's litter like a
snake snakes have a very effective way
of moving they are covered in scales
that make them very smooth if you rub
them one way but then they are actually
quite rough if you rub them the other
way and this allows them to get traction
against the ground and it allows them to
push on the ground and basically move in
a forward direction so the snake scales
grip the ground to slither along
but how can a robot pull off a similar
maneuver so this is the very same
principle that these engineers are using
for the robot snake but instead of
building scales and making skin they
attach a set of wheels on robot body
and wheels function the same way as a
scale if you ever try to roll a wheel
forward it's very easy if you try to
roll or slide the wheel sideways not so
easy so what the robot does when its
slithering forward it uses the wheel
sideway friction to hold off against and
that way it can push itself forward so
it's pretty cool it gets this littering
snake motion by using the sideways
friction concept